Oh, don't worry.
Society expects plenty from women.
We're expected to age gracefully
but never let ourselves go work like we have no children
and parent like we have no job.
They'll call the stay at home mother unfulfilled,
but the working mother selfish,
all while childless women are considered incomplete.
Go chase that career, but never at the expense of a family.
Think like a man if you wanna be successful,
but don't act like one if you wanna be liked.
We're supposed to mother our husbands,
but never treat them like children.
And put out on demand, but demand respect.
Married and miserable is better than single and happy.
Don't stay with an abusive man,
but never break up your family.
Don't marry a bum for love,
but don't stay with a successful man for security.
Don't be dependent on a man for money,
but don't emasculate them by earning more.
They tell us to embrace our sexuality,
but have some self respect and to care about our appearance,
but stop looking for attention.
Just say no, but let him down easy.
Be aware of your surroundings,
but stop being so dramatic.
Practice self love, but don't love yourself too much.
Dream big, but stay small. And would you like.